Let's go ahead and bring uh Tanto up.
Tanto, how you doing, man?
>> Good. How are you?
>> Pretty good. Pretty good. You uh what's
your religion?
>> I'm agnostic.
>> Okay. So, you uh
>> you're just Jewish if that helps,
>> I guess. So, you uh so you disagree that
Jesus is God?
>> Yeah. Well, I I have one main question.
I I find like don't get me wrong, I love
all the stuff you do with Islam and blah
blah blah, but the Islamic dilemma has a
very similar issue that Christians have
with the Torah.
>> Oh, really? So we so we say that the
Torah we say the New Testament confirms
the Torah while the Torah is corrupted
and we say the Torah is corrupted.
>> No, not that bad. Not that bad. But you
you affirm the Torah and the Torah
doesn't quite affirm Jesus in your in
your eyes, but it doesn't really when
you look into it. There's a few things
that could be misconstrued as Jesus.
>> Can you can you show us how it goes
against Jesus?
>> Well, yeah. Jesus hasn't completed any
of the me the messianic prophecies.
>> Can you give me one in the Torah? He
didn't complete.
>> Well, that he didn't complete.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, he didn't turn the go he didn't
turn weapons into garden tool.
>> Yeah. So, let's let's go to the verse.
What verse do you want to go to in the
Torah?
>> I don't I don't remember the garden tool
one.
>> What verse is it? The
>> where Jesus is where the Messiah will
turn all of the weapons in the world
into into garden tools and things.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What verse is that?
>> I I don't know. I don't remember. I'm
I'm not I'm not as talking about Isaiah
chapter 2. That's not even in the Torah.
>> No, there's m Well, there's Okay, so
let's say there's multiple verses.
>> Isaiah 2 is not what you're talking
about, bro. So,
>> no, I think that there's two or three
different ones.
>> Yeah, you Isaiah chapter 2, I think
verse four. Oh,
>> you can use another one if you want.
>> That's not even like
>> is there peace in the world?
>> What do you mean is there peace in the
world?
>> Well, there's only a few prophecies in
the in the Torah.
>> Bro, just give me like one in the Torah
that
>> I don't have them to hand. I'm asking.
you guys should know. No,
>> you No, we disagree with that. You're
the one making the claim that he doesn't
fulfill the Torah and give us a one.
>> Well, I Okay, well, I'll read through
what the messianic prophecies in the
Torah are.
>> Okay, we just want one. Yeah, we just
want one that you can find in the Torah
that he did not fulfill.
>> Well, he wasn't from Abraham. He wasn't
from the line of Abraham, was he?
>> Yes.
>> How?
>> Through David.
>> Through who? Who's his dad?
>> But who's his dad? Well, he doesn't have
a biological dad, but
>> so he's not from the line of David.
>> Yes.
>> Through Mary,
>> but that's not what it says, does it?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, it's not what we say.
>> It says that you would have to be I
believe that I I know that obviously
Jews go through their mom to tell
whether they're Jewish or not, but to
take your father's name and you would go
through the father's lineage for things
like that. So,
>> you can also go to the mother for that.
It's not
>> I don't think you can.
>> Well, you're going to have to prove that
then.
>> All right. So, so let me give you an
example of of proving that explicitly
and then you show me otherwise. Okay.
So, we're going to go to Chronicles.
>> Okay.
>> Go, we'll go to Chronicles
2. We're going to go to Shashan. You you
familiar with Shashan? All right. I take
that as a no. So, here it says in
second, this is 1 Chronicles 2:35. It
says, "So, Shashan, I'm sorry. Let's
read uh 34."
>> One second. I'm just I'm not Give me one
second and then I'll I'll be with you.
Sorry. I want to at least listen.
>> I got it on the screen for you. Okay.
One sec.
>> So now Shashan had no sons, only
daughters. But Shashan had an Egyptian
slave whose name was Jar. So Shashan
gave his daughter in marriage to Jar,
his slave. And she bore him a Thai. A
Thai fathered Nathan. And Nathan Zabad.
Zabad fathered Efflaw. And Ephlaw
fathered Oed. This is the genealogy of
David continuing even when one of them
didn't have sons. They can only continue
through the daughters. So the daughters
continue the line of David here. Make
sense?
>> Okay.
>> So Jesus is a descendant of David
through his mother and his adopted
father at the same time. Both sides.
>> Okay. So I'm trying to find the verses
for you. It's been a long time since
I've learned all this stuff. I studied
it when I was a kid.
>> Well, you're an agnostic. Why don't you
believe Jesus is God?
>> Because there's there's extreme evidence
that uh Beres was written by four or
five different authors.
>> What does that got to do with him being
God?
>> Sorry, with who?
>> With Jesus being God.
>> Well, without the Torah, Jesus, nothing
that Jesus happens can can be real, can
it?
>> Without the Torah, nothing can be real.
>> Nothing that Jesus can claim can be real
without the Torah being true. Yes.
>> So, what is he what what about the Torah
discounts Jesus's claims? Well, for for
me, the well, I've just told you what I
what I learned when I was younger is
that there's a few there's, I believe,
six or seven different me Msiah
prophecies, and you and Christians claim
that he's going to come back and fulfill
them.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. But which ones in the Torah? You
haven't actually given us one in the
Torah.
>> You haven't given us anything, bro.
>> Well, I I'm trying to look and then
you're making me read something else,
but I I told you a few of the different
things that the Messiah will do when he
comes back that you know that you
believe.
>> The first one you gave wasn't even in
the Torah.
>> Okay. All right. But Isaiah is is is a
scroll that can be considered within
Hebrew scripture.
>> It's in it's in the Tanakh.
>> Yeah. It's not in the Torah though. Your
whole point was that he disagrees with
the Torah that he doesn't things in the
Torah.
>> Okay. The restoration of law and destiny
in dynasty, rebuilding the temple, the
return to Israel, holding the hands of
where does it say that the hands say
that the Messiah will rebuild the
temple.
>> Yeah. What verse you referring to?
>> A major focus of the messianic age.
>> We're just reading an article. Are you
are you are you on Jews for Judaism?
>> I'm on Google actually. You're the one
who asked me to bring it up.
>> I'm questioning it to join.
>> What article are you reading off of
right now?
>> Google. Just the main page.
>> Yeah. So, they're showing you different
articles. What What are you reading on?
>> No, I'm literally reading Google AI,
bro. Like, like So, does it actually
give you a verse?
>> Okay, one sec. And I'll ask for an
actual verse.
>> We arguing against AI logic, bro. That's
what it's called.
>> No, you're not arguing against AI. I
don't care. I've told you why I don't
believe in the Torah.
>> But your your source right now you're
bringing is just AI. You don't actually
have any verses.
>> Well, no. You asked me about the Torah
and I told you why I don't believe in
the Torah.
>> I said give us a single verse in the
Torah that he didn't fulfill.
>> 49:10.
>> 49:10. What?
>> Genesis 49:10.
>> Okay. What didn't he fill in Genesis 49?
>> Jacob refers to who will bring peace?
The Mash the Messiah. And then you've
got I don't know 24:17
in Numbers.
>> 49:10. And the scepter shall not depart
from Judah, nor a lawgiver from between
his feet until Shiloh comes and to him
shall be the obedience of the people.
What do you mean he does have obedience
of his people?
>> Who?
>> So, so it it seems like
>> obedience of the people.
>> Look, Ton Tanto, just just respectfully,
man. It doesn't seem like you're you're
prepared to have this discussion. You're
bringing up accusations against Jesus
that you yourself don't really have, but
you're going to look stuff up and
different articles and and so we're
we're not
>> No, I told you what my issue personally
was being agnostic was that I don't
believe in the Torah and and the main
difference between the Torah and New
Testament.
>> Why don't you believe in the Torah?
>> I told you because there's four to five
different authors of
>> How does How does that negate the Torah?
>> Well, it doesn't claim to be four or
five different authors and then four or
five different people clearly wrote it.
What what does that have to do with
making how does how does four author the
>> only how does four authors make the
Torah false?
>> Because it claims that there's only one
author.
>> Where does it say that?
>> In in in the first in the book of
Genesis was written by who?
>> Where does it say that that there's only
one author that
>> Genesis was written by who? Moses.
>> Can you Can you answer the question?
>> Huh?
>> Can you answer the question? Where does
the Where in the Torah does it say that
it's only written by one author?
>> Well, isn't it written by Moses?
>> Bro,
>> I'm I'm going to give you another
chance. I I don't know where it's
written. I don't know where
>> it it doesn't. But you said it claimed
that. So the the Torah never claims
>> making stuff up. It doesn't exist.
>> But it doesn't make the claim, but it it
gives off the impression. Yes.
>> Subjective.
>> It's not Don't use subjective. It
doesn't give off the impression.
>> Subjective. No, I don't think No,
because we even know. We even know
towards the ending of of the of the
Torah, right, that it's written by
Aaron.
>> At the very end when it talks about
Moses's death, it's Aaron that's writing
it. So, we don't even believe that it
was all written by one author.
Everything there.
>> Take care, man.
>> A waste of time, you guys. Y'all got to
come better than this, guys. Come on,
man. Like, stop wasting my time. Stop
wasting Nick's time. Can we get some
some better people, man? Like,
seriously, man. Y'all making our numbers
drop. Good grief. We was at We was at
3,000 earlier. We get a a a range of
tarded res in a row, man. When you guys
have arguments or you have objections,
make sure you're ready to present them.
Please and thank you. Appreciate it.
Come up if you disagree. Only Professor
V on Tik Tok raising you update.
[Music]
>> All right, I'm going just refresh. I'mma
go ahead and refresh. Refresh the guest
request on Tik Tok. Y'all let me y'all
y'all request up when you guys know that
you disagree. Do not request up if you
agree, please. Big Vaz, how you doing?
Hey, uh you just said not to request up
if you agree, but uh I I do agree. It's
just I have some questions.
>> This can't be. I know you told me not to
come, but I'm coming anyways.
>> All right. Okay. Well, thanks. Thanks,
Tik Tok. I appreciate y'all for for
trying. Michael, how you doing? You're
on stage. Do you disagree?
>> I I disagree that
>> that the um the Trinity, but I don't
disagree in Christianity. I am a
Christian, but I don't agree with the
Trinity.
>> If you're not a If you don't agree with
the Trinity, then you're not a Christian
just yet, my friend. That's not true.
That's not true, my friend.
>> Very true. Very true.
>> No, he's not, my friend. Prove it to me,
my friend.
>> All right.
>> I know. I know. I know.
>> Is Jesus God, bro?
>> Yes. Jesus is God.
>> Is he the father?
>> Yes, he is the father.
>> Okay. You believe the Holy Spirit is the
father?
>> Of course.
>> Does the father speak on anybody else's
authority?
>> No. On his own.
>> Does the father hear from anyone else?
>> No. The father answer to no one.
>> Okay. So, I want to show you a verse and
I want you to tell
>> I know all the verses you're going to go
to practice.
>> All right. What vers what verse am I
about to go to?
>> I know y'all going to go to Genesis and
say Elohim. I know you're going to go to
Genesis. I know you're going to say
>> you couldn't be further off.
>> I mean, can you give me time, bro?
>> But you're wrong.
>> Dead wrong. Like, you
>> I know that's the scripture that y'all
>> 50 books away from where he about to go.
I never even used the term Elohim in a
argue as an argument against oneness
folk.
>> Yeah. Ever.
>> It's good. I'm not oneness though.
>> Yeah, you are.
>> No.
>> I work at a store that sells only books,
but I don't work at a library.
>> But I'm saying y'all going to tell me
what I am without even trying to hear my
>> Yes. We're going to tell you what you
are because you are are are unaware of
what you are. Man, it's it's okay.
>> I play in the NBA, but I'm not a
basketball player.
>> Okay, let's go.
>> All right. So remember what we just
said. You said that the father
>> speaks on his own authority. He doesn't
speak on anybody else's authority and
that he doesn't have to hear from anyone
else. Right.
>> Right.
>> John.
>> All right.
>> Chapter 16.
>> So here we go. On the left we got John
chapter 16 just as Nick prophesied.
Verse 13. It says when the spirit of
truth comes that's the Holy Spirit.
Right.
>> Right.
>> Okay. Who you believe is the father.
>> God.
>> The father. Right. Right.
>> All right. So when the spirit of truth
comes, who is also the father, he who is
also the father will guide you into all
truth. For he who is also the father
will not speak on his own authority, but
whatever he hears, he will speak. And he
will declare to you the things that are
to come. He'll glorify me for he will
take what is mine and declare it to you.
All right? So the father doesn't speak
on anyone else's authority nor does he
hear from anyone else but you insist
that the spirit of truth is the father.
>> So who is the father hearing from and
whose authority is the father speaking
on?
>> The father is hearing from no one. The
father is himself. He he does what he
wants. He he does whatever he wants.
>> So that means that this can't be the
father here because this person the
spirit of truth will not speak on his
own authority. So he's speaking on
someone else's authority. So that's not
the father right? No, that's not true.
>> So, it is the father.
>> Yes.
>> So, whose authority is
>> All of it. All of it is the father.
>> So, whose authority is the father
speaking on?
>> On his own behalf.
>> It says it's not on his own.
>> But it is on his own behalf.
>> So then you believe the Bible's wrong.
>> No, I don't. I actually agree with it.
But the way it's explained, I don't
agree with.
>> The way it's explained, we didn't
explain anything. It says it right here.
Very explicit.
>> That's all we do.
>> I'm not I'm not saying you. I'm saying
other people, you know. So, I'm trying
to Y'all are already jumping ahead. You
know, y'all already trying to think.
>> I'm not jumping anywhere, brother. We
only in the verse. Will he speak on his
own authority? Yes or no, my brother?
>> No. You said he will not speak on his
own authority.
>> So, whose authority will he speak on?
>> He speak on the father. He's talking
about the spirit,
>> right? This is the father.
>> So, the father's not going to speak on
his own authority.
>> The father speaks on his own authority.
>> On whose authority is the father
speaking on then here? Because you're
saying this is the father. The father is
speaking on behalf of his own authority.
See, you got to go to the verse, but I'm
trying to explain to you how what
scriptures I have. I understand what you
saying. You trying to twist me up, but
you not seeing what
>> I'm not trying to twist you up at all,
brother. I love you. I want you to have
the truth. I believe that.
>> I know you love I know you I know who
you are. I know you love me, Logic. I
know who you are. I watch your videos. I
support you. I really agree with like
for real. I do.
>> Awesome. So, let's get We got to get
down because you if you watch my videos,
then you know that I don't let up on
verses, man. You know,
>> I already know. You be trying to cook
them. You be cooking. I ain't going to
lie.
>> All right. So, now So now, so now we got
to I got I can't be impartial, you know?
So,
>> I already know it.
>> So, with this man, if the father does
not speak on his own authority, I'm
sorry. If the father speaks on his own
authority, right, he doesn't have to
speak on anybody else's. He's the
father.
>> He speaks on his own authority. He
doesn't hear from anyone else. He's the
father. Okay, we get that,
>> right?
>> So then
>> this means that the spirit of truth is
not the father. He's someone else who
speaks on somebody else's authority.
Bro,
>> okay. I got a question for you. Who is
the spirit of truth?
>> He's the holy spirit. The one who comes
out from the father.
>> Okay. If he comes out of the father,
right? You said he comes out of the
father, right? So he is the father's
being, right? He shares the same being
as the father.
>> No, I'm asking you. Is he the father's
being?
>> No, I say he shares the same being that
the father has. The same being that the
father has, the spirit of truth, the
holy spirit also has because he comes
out of the father.
>> Okay. Now I got to ask Okay. Now I got
to ask this question. So you're saying
that you said that he's not the same as
the father, right?
>> He's the same being as the father, not
the same person.
>> Not the same person. Okay. What will
make them different?
>> The fact that he comes out of the
father. That's the distinction.
>> How does how does that make him? How
does that a distinction?
>> Because if something is coming out of
something, there's a there's a
distinction between the thing that's
coming out and the thing that it's
coming out from. Those are two different
things. Would you agree?
>> No. So if I say um if you you you're in
your body, right? And if your spirit
comes out to your body, is that you or
is that a different person?
>> That that's a part of me. If the if if
the spirit comes out of my body, that
that that demonstrates the spirit is not
my the spirit is not my body though, is
it?
>> But the spirit is you.
>> I got you. But is the spirit my body?
>> No, cuz your body is flesh. It's going
to die anyway. That's not the real you.
>> I got you. So if the spirit comes out of
my body, there's a distinction between
my body and the spirit that comes out of
my body. Right.
>> But the body the spirit is you who you
>> I got you. But is that correct?
>> Yeah. that both of them are you. There's
not
>> Okay. So, so what we're saying is is
that both of them both the father and
the holy spirit are god but there's a
distinction between the father and the
spirit because the spirit is coming out
of the father. So they're one and the
same in one sense meaning in their
essence. They share the same divine
essence. They're inseparable. However,
they are distinct in their personhood.
The son I mean the spirit and the father
are two distinct persons. Because
there's a distinction between the spirit
who comes out of the father and the
father who spirates the spirit.
>> That's not a distinction. A distinction
is a big difference. If I say a
distinction is you
>> in reality, bro.
>> So if you if your spirit comes out of
you, right? If your spirit comes out of
you, you're saying it's a distinction
between you. Your flesh is just the
flesh. It's not really it's decaying.
Your spirit is what makes it alive. So
your spirit come out of us the way that
the Holy Spirit comes out of the father
though.
>> But yes it did. When you die your spirit
come out of you. What are you talking
about?
>> Okay. Our spirit comes out of our body.
But then our body no longer has life in
it.
>> Body I know that. But it's you. Your
spirit is actually who you are. It's
actually you. It's your whole being.
It's you as a being. The spirit. Your
body is you because of the spirit. If
your body didn't have a spirit, it
wouldn't be you.
>> No, your body's not you, bro. Because
you can separate from your body.
>> All right. So,
so if you So, if you So, if you like are
unalived, right? And your body is in the
grave. Whose body is in the grave.
>> My body is in the grave, though. But my
being, who I really am is not in the
grave.
>> But it's you.
>> Who I really am.
>> It's you. It's your body is in the
grave.
>> Yeah. It's my body.
>> When Christ died for three days, who was
in the grave?
>> You said what? When Christ died for
three days, who was in the grave?
>> Christ was in the grave.
>> Christ was in the grave. Even though
Christ was in the grave.
>> He was He really wasn't in the grave. He
was in the tomb. But Okay. So,
>> that's what I mean. In the tomb. So,
Christ was in the tomb even though his
spirit wasn't there.
>> Right.
>> Okay. So, even though your spirit's
gone, that's still you.
>> Okay. So, what's the distinction though?
>> The distinction both of them are Holy
Spirit is going to be they have
different properties to their
>> All right. Let me give y Let me Let me
give y'all the scripture though since
y'all throwing y scriptures.
>> No, no, no. We We need this. I need this
answered.
>> You got We We can't leave this.
>> Okay.
>> You have to You have to reconcile how
the father cuz you're saying the spirit
is the same person as the father. You
have to reconcile how the father is
hearing from somebody else. Who is he
hearing from? You have to reconcile
that.
>> It very clearly says it's not his
mother.
>> The father is the only reason why Jesus
is less because he is human. He's man.
>> We're not talking about Jesus. We're
talking about the father. It says that
the father it said you it says you say
that the father is the holy spirit is
the spirit of truth. It says the spirit
of truth will be hearing from somebody
else
>> from the father.
>> But that is it says
>> the same person. Do you understand like
like for Michael cuz like I really want
>> I promise I promise I understand what
you're trying to say. I promise. But I
promise like I promise I understand what
you're trying to say. I promise I do.
You saying that the father is the one
that's talking to the spirit and sends
the spirit out and I I know exactly what
you're saying.
>> So, but so, but do you understand that
like the the dilemma that you're in by
saying that the Holy Spirit is the
father? Do you see the dilemma here with
this verse?
>> No, because it's multiple verses. You
just go to that one verse, but it's
multiple verses that
>> according to this verse, bro. And
>> I mean, I feel what you're saying.
>> I promise I promise I feel what you're
saying.
>> According to this verse, I just want to
know. I just want to know if if we're
reading the same thing
>> literally. So
according to the verse, will he speak on
his own authority?
>> Okay. No, no, no.
>> Okay. So he will not speak on his own
authority. The father speaks on his own
authority. Right.
>> Right.
So therefore, this person here who
doesn't speak on his own authority can't
be the father who speaks on his own
authority. Right.
>> Right. I guess. Right. Right. Right.
>> Well, then that means that the spirit of
truth here is not the father. He's
somebody else.
>> That that does not mean that.
>> Right.
>> Look. Okay. So, can I give you the can I
give you what it means? What is what
>> like I get what he's saying. I know what
he's saying. I promise I know what he's
saying. I know y'all making this. I know
it look like I don't know what I'm
talking about,
>> but I really do know what I'm talking
about.
>> I love that.
>> I'm telling you, bro.
>> Real life, bro.
>> I'm not Y'all Y'all ain't even gave me
no time to even try to give no
scripture, though. That's crazy, though.
>> Look Look, I I don't I don't I don't
know what you want from me, man. I I
>> I just want to explain. I just want to
explain.
>> Okay. Break this break this down. Break
this down. If you break this down and
you make it make sense in one modalism
theology,
>> are you are you saying not one of those
modes?
>> I'm not I'm not I'm not modalism.
>> Okay. But if you can make this make
sense in regard that right there,
>> father spirit. I got two or three women
in the scripture that can make reference
and go to this scripture that make
>> I need you to reconcile this.
>> I got you, Logic. You right on this. I
ain't I can't lie. You right.
>> You right.
>> Amen.
>> You right. I can't I can't do it on this
one. But I can I know what you saying,
but I also still in a in a way kind of
see it a different way though. You see
what I'm like? If I'm right on this,
then there is no other way to see it
other than
>> unless you let me.
>> Of course. Of course you there's no
other way to see it because you're not
letting me get other scriptures that
correlate with these scriptures. So of
course this of course. Come on, man. The
Bible say
I got you. Because you said I'm right on
this. I'll give you a chance. Give me
one verse that helps you reconcile this
with your theology. If it doesn't work
and you don't admit that it doesn't
work, then I'm gonna have to move on.
But I need you to be honest. Say, I'm
giving you opportunity. You got the
floor, wherever you want to throw in the
Bible,
>> but I need you to be honest that if it
don't work, you got to admit it.
>> I promise I don't admit lie. I promise.
If you right, you right. Now, you hear
me? It's just how I am. All right. So,
we can go to Genesis um chapter uh one.
And you know Genesis chapter one. So it
says in the beginning God, right? And
then it says in the spirit of God and
then you go down to verse 26 and it says
let us. So God is literally talking to
the spirit of himself which we know that
even uh Peter confirms it. And we know
that John says that Jesus was in the
bosom of the father which means that he
placed the spirit of himself inside
Mary's womb which is how Jesus is God.
Then you go to Peter who says no
prophecy was given by a man but on the
by the Holy Spirit which is God which
was in his being. And then you have um
>> so you so you believe so you believe the
trinity. I mean, I wouldn't I just don't
like that word. I mean, cuz the Bible
don't say trinity, man. He's not three
persons. When I think of three persons,
I'm thinking of three distinct three
different people with three different
personalities. When all together, they
all had one will and all in the same to
save us all. God multiplied himself with
Moses when he um placed his spirit on
multiple people. So, we know that God
can multiply his spirit. We know that
God is not just a spirit. But you going
to say, y'all going to say God is a
spirit. But the Bible don't say that.
The Bible said God is spirit, which
means he is life. As we can look at
Ezekiel, we see that even angels are not
just spirits that they have a body. So
they have a body and their spirits are
>> brother. Brother, I I I let you work it
out, did I not?
>> Hey, you did though. I ain't gonna lie.
>> Let you work it out. I just don't agree
with the the three distinct because it's
like it's saying that
>> in Genesis 1, who is the spirit hearing
from?
>> The spirit is not hearing from nothing.
It never said that the spirit hears from
anything.
>> All right. So when it say
>> the spirit hovered
>> I got you. So when God says let us make
man in our image, who did you say that
God was talking to?
>> He was talking to himself. the spirit
that came out of his being that came out
of the
>> So who's who I mean didn't God just
multiply his spirit
>> specifically specifically who's the one
saying let us make man in our image
who's who's saying that
>> the spirit of God
>> the spirit is saying
>> yes that's just like me saying logic
>> I got you Norris who's the spirit saying
that to
>> God which is himself
>> so the spirit is speaking to someone who
is identified as God
>> himself the spirit God is speaking to
himself. God pulled his spirit out of
his body, which I don't see how y'all
think that is uh insane or not logical
knowing that he's the most powerful
being. He can't talk to himself. I mean,
>> I got you. So, you're saying that the
spirit is talking to himself. There's
nobody else around. When he says, "Let
us make man in our image." He's not
talking to anybody else
>> but himself. If I if I
>> wait he's talking to himself I'll I'll
go with you. So if he's talking to
himself
>> how does that help what we read earlier
>> where it says that he will be hearing
from someone else. Let me explain it.
Okay. If I say logic you are over there.
Logic is in heaven. Right. So logic the
spirit of logic came out. It's still
logic. It's just his spirit. Now, Elijah
commands his spirit to go and multiply
on Moses. The spirit is getting the word
from the father, which who is the
father. You just have that ability
because you're God. Nobody can explain.
>> So, so to be clear, the f he's hearing
from himself,
>> right?
>> But it says he won't be hearing from
himself.
>> Is he hearing from himself?
>> He's hearing from the father. I mean, if
we all believe that Jesus is God and God
is the Holy Spirit and how are they how
are they all different? That's what I'm
trying to say.
>> This this lasted as long this lasted as
long as it did because you have a good
spirit. I do you're cool. So that's why
it last did if you were any you would
you would have been gone. I'm not I'm
not
>> I already know like I already know.
True. I already know man and I agree
with you. I just don't I just don't like
the word you know. I agree with
everything. I believe Jesus.
>> You don't agree with everything. You
literally don't agree with it.
>> You don't?
>> I'm just Man, look, you got me, L. I
can't even defute that. You hear me? I
can't do it. I can't do it, man. I can't
do it.
>> So, then why not submit to the
scripture? And what it's
>> I actually am I actually am going to
submit to the scripture life.
>> So, you're going to submit that this
Holy Spirit is distinct from the father
in his personhood.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Hey, man.
>> Yeah. Because I mean I feel what you're
saying. You know what I'm saying? I
don't know if you understood what I was
saying, but
>> I understand what you're saying. That's
that's why I attacked it this way. The
reason I I the reason why I'm bringing
up this verse and still pointing back to
this verse is cuz I know exactly what
your point is. I know what you're
saying.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> It doesn't make sense in light of this.
It doesn't It doesn't fall through.
>> And I'm good. I'm good to correction, my
guy. I ain't I study the Bible, the
Greek, and the Hebrew. If I'm wrong, I'm
wrong, bro. This is how it is.
>> You know what I'm saying? And so I can't
defeat the word. It has to final
authority, bro.
>> So now what we have to do is, and I
think that you would agree with this as
you just demonstrated, we have to warp
our world view to the scripture instead
of warping the scripture to our world
view.
What's the first thing?
>> Boom. I could use somebody like you on
on my team now. So you're getting close.
So with that being said, now we look at
the rest of scripture in light of what
we just conceded to in the scripture
that when we see in Genesis 1, we see
the spirit is there. We see God is
speaking. There really is a plurality
within the unity of God that Yeah. You
see it?
>> Yeah. I I saw that in Exodus when he
spreaded his spirit all over the elders.
>> Even in even in um in Acts too. I mean
we know he's proud. He can make himself
one three places. He can be everywhere.
>> You know I'm prison. That's the whole
point.
>> Yes.
>> So I I just I just the trinity it just
kind of you know I just don't like the
word because it confuses people a lot.
It it it only it it won't confuse you if
you just if you go with the scripture
and you just go with what the scripture
is saying. That that this is why the
trinity is the only thing that makes
sense to me, bro. Like I I can't if if I
read the scripture outside of a
trinitarian lens, then this this doesn't
make any sense. You have God speaking in
the plural,
>> but it's supposed to be one at the same
time. But then you have the spirit who
comes and is sent by the father, but
it's, you know, and then you have Jesus,
who's the word of God, who was God,
taking on flesh, being sent by the
father and them talking to each other
and glorifying like what? The only way
this makes sense is if God is absolutely
singular in his essence. There's only
one divine essence, one God who exists
as a plurality of persons, the father,
the word, the son, and the spirit who co
who coexist and fellowship with each
other inseparably,
indivisibly together from eternity's
past. That makes sense from if I'm
reading the scripture how it is.
>> I feel what you're saying. And you and
also the trinity does be taught wrong a
lot. So that's
>> you're absolutely right. And people be
confused. And I that's why what made me
not like the word because when you read
in the Hebrew it says divine nature. It
doesn't say God or trinity or anything
like that. And it confuses a lot of
people.
>> Yes. So we look we got to we got to
stick to the scripture. And I would say
it it's similar to how cuz I I know the
word trinity isn't in the Bible so this
wouldn't be an exact example but the
word Christian you know how Peter says
you know to when you suffer as being a
Christian rejoice in that name and stuff
like that.
>> Antioch. Yes, in Antioch too, in Acts
11. And then there's in Peter
>> Peter talks about rejoicing under the
name of being called Christian even when
you suffer under that name. He says,
"Rejoice in the Lord under that name."
>> Now it but it it would be like me taking
that and saying, "Okay, yeah, but
looking at Christians in this world."
>> Uhoh. Hold on.
>> But but I see what y'all saying. I see
and fearless. Yeah. You on my number,
man. I got
>> Yeah, I hear you. Okay. For sure, bro.
>> It'll be like me me taking, you know,
the term Christian and looking at the
rest of these Christians who are
lukewarm or hypocrites and not really
following the word and being like,
"Yeah, I don't like the word Christian,
man." Cuz people done they they done
distorted it, man. They mis
>> Yeah. People say that all the time, but
they're wrong.
>> Because
to us being Christians, it tells us to
rejoice in that name and represent
Christ correctly. Same thing with the
Trinity. Even though the word Trinity
isn't there, you do have people that
misrepresent what the Trinity is. They
don't articulate it correctly. However,
that doesn't mean discard it. It's
scripture. The the concept of the
Trinity, God being one in essence, three
in his personhood, them being
inseparable and united perfectly in
fellowship, that is in the scripture.
The Trinity is in the scripture. So
don't discard it just because people
confuse it and misread we're glad you
finally understand the correct view now
though
>> like like I do I understood like I said
it's been confusing with the with the
trinity and people be you know just
coming up with their own stuff and not
first Corinthians 4:6 you know
>> so so I get what you're saying a lot
>> I get it and I appreciate it for real
>> I appreciate you man you know I almost
lost hope I'm not
>> don't lose hope on the brother hope
brother man
>> I can't Man, you're right. You're right.
That that's a part, you know. But man,
it's a it's a good thing that the Holy
Spirit led you here and Amen.
>> gave me gave me the all, you know, the
patience and the comp companionship or
compassion to even, you know, continue
talking to you, Brad, cuz I know how
that patience going through, man.
>> Yeah, man. I'm only human, man.
>> Cuz I seen you with a lot of people. I'm
like, man, he must got some patience on
him cuz ain't no way in the world. I
salute you for this, [__]
>> Where you from, Michael?
>> I'm from Memphis.
>> Where you from? Memphis. All right. All
right. I ain't mad at I can I can hear
it on your accent. You from you country.
I just know that.
>> Yeah, definitely. But I'm in them
scriptures every day, though.
>> That's good. Keep it that way, bro.
>> But now, now you can look at it with
this view, though.
>> Yeah. And I appreciate y'all for real.
>> If you if you if you have any questions,
man. Uh you can hit me up, man. I'll be
on Instagram, Tik Tok. I don't know if
you use those. Email me and be like,
"Hey, yo, this is Michael, man. We had
the conversation with, you know, just
remind me." And then uh and yeah, we
could connect. All right. Just stay
connected. Yeah. Yeah. I got you.
>> All right. God bless you, bro.
>> Pleasure talking to you.
>> God bless you.
>> All right.
>> All right. Peace.
>> Yo, I don't know what it is, but like
there's been it's like the third person
today that like they're trinitarian.
They just don't know it. I don't know
what it is.
>> Yeah. Well, he was he was clearly one.
>> Yeah, you're right. He definitely was.
He's definitely was one that. But there
was the other two before that were like
trinitarian.
>> But towards the end, he started saying
he you know what I mean? Like what the
trinity was,
>> but just saying he wasn't like
Trinitarian. I'm like, bro, like it just
people have an issue with the word. I
feel like they got it's like a stigma.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it is like a man, bro. I
might just say that, man.
>> Yeah. Praise God. Goodness gracious,
dude.
>> Why the goat? I'm telling y'all. Stop.
Now you'll